hi hi thanks balloon boy for the assist
I'm gonna high-five you later before I
punch you in the face and I'm gonna
punch you in the face some more just cuz
I don't like you I'm gonna hug ya
oh damn it there he is hey buddy how's
it going you might want to check out
room 10 because room 10 oh boy let me
tell you all the stuff is in room 10
room 10 oh it's got amazing this cake
there's bunny rabbits flowing out
everywhere you love it
I seem to be in a bit of trouble don't
worry about the flashing light let's
just have a conversation you and me
because I really want to get to know you
as a person cuz I know there's a person
in there and I know you're a person at
heart and you're really kind and
cherished and you know I feel a deeper
connection now that we're looking at
each other in the eyes excuse me for a
second I'm gonna should be fine 4 a.m.
plenty of time Freddy come on in we'll
have a nice tea party and then he can go
[ __ ] himself if he's just in my doorway
I'm just gonna have a nice little tea
party with him hey oh you know what I
just met your friends like chica and
blue boy came back together we had a big
gang bang together we had so much fun in
a big orgy pile with all the spare parts
it was great let me tell you oh let me
tell you all the improvements that
chicas made ah you really classed up her
face by smudging dirt everywhere and
then Balloon Boy God you know he was
annoying before now he graduated to
terrifying and you're not listening to
me are you
goddamn back back back back
Phi Phi [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you you you and me we get along so
well these days I really feel you know
staring into your eyes this long
scientists prove that it builds a
connection between two people and you
know all in all the lights may be
blaring but I'd like to think about the
red-hot burning love that I feel in my
heart for you yeah haha would you do pew
I love you at all